الروبوتات الأليفة
التي يتحكم فيها العقل والآلات الأحدث
في المركبات الذاتية ،
إنها نظرة خاطفة على المستقبل
مستوحاة من جيل جديد من
معمل الحالمين كان بمثابة منصة انطلاق للشركات الأوروبية
الرائدة
في مجال الابتكار وهذا العام هو
التنقل الذي يحتل مركز الصدارة في
هذا  هو مستقبل تسليم الميل الأخير ،
آمل أن يكون الناس أفضل في
قيادتها من أنا
مرحبًا بالجميع الذين حصلوا على تمويل جماعي في عام 2019 ،
ترغب الشركة البريطانية في سد
الفجوة بين الدراجة والشاحنة التي تعمل
بالفعل في إنتاج مركبة الشحن الإلكترونية الثانية.
قطع المسافة التي تم
تصميمها وبناءها بشكل أساسي
لغرض واحد وهو آخر ميل آخر
منطقة ميل
من صناعة الخدمات اللوجستية الموجودة في
المملكة المتحدة
وعشية أوروبا دخلت مؤخرًا
سوق الولايات المتحدة
، التكلفة الإجمالية للملكية أه
حوالي ربع  a من
شاحنة عادية متوسطة الحجم ، الشاحنة التقليدية التي
تقوم بتسليم آخر ميل ، ما الذي
يفعله هذا بحيث لا يمكن أن تفعله
في مدينة تقوم بعملها  تبلغ 20
30 ميلاً في الساعة مؤقتًا ،
لكن متوسط سرعتك عبر ال
دينة في شاحنة تقل عن خم
ة أميال في الساعة ، وبهذا يمكنك ضم
ن وقت الرحلة تقريبًا حتى تتمكن من ال
زول في ممر للدراجات عبر مناطق المشاة ، فق
يستغرق الأمر  طريق مختلف تمامًا
عبر وسط المدينة ، أحد أكثر
العناصر إثارة في المختبر المستقبلي هو
مجرد رؤية كيف تعيد الشركات المختلفة
التفكير في التنقل
بمجرد فقد محرك الاحتراق
ونظام العادم وخزان الوقود ،
يمكنك فقط نسخ دفتر القواعد عندما
يأتي
لتصميم سيارة لا يجب أن تبدو وكأنها واحدة ،
إذا كنت ترغب في التغلب على حركة المرور
المصممة من قبل شركة بولندية تريغو ، هذه
السيارة التي هي نموذج أولي
يتحول من سيارة إلى دراجة نارية
بعد مزيج من التمويل الخاص
والمنح العامة.
للجمهور هذا
العام ويهدف إلى ظهور علامات تريجوس في
الشوارع في عام 2022.
تضغط على زر واحد لتوسيعه
والآخر لسحبه ،
لدينا حيلتان أخريان في
الأكمام للتجربة  لو أن جهاز التحكم عن بعد الذي يمكن
أن يجعله في
سيارة يتم تسليمه لك
بشكل مستقل سواء كانت
ذاتية القيادة
أو سيعمل شخص ما أو شخص ما عن بعد ،
فهل سيكون هذا في
النهاية تاكسي روبو في
النهاية سيكون بمجرد أن
يصبح الحكم الذاتي
قانونيًا على الطريق  وفقًا لبيانات من
منصات الأعمال ، فإن
الاستثمار في القاعدية والصفقات والشركات الناشئة الأوروبية قد
تجاوزت قيمتها 50 مليار دولار في النصف الأول
من عام 2021
بأكثر من ضعف الفترة نفسها من العام الماضي ،
لكن التنظيم لا يزال
أحد أكبر التحديات التي تواجه
الشركات
الهولندية للتصدير.  تهدف إلى تحقيق أهداف عالية
تبدو وكأنها سيارات ، ولكن انتظر حتى يتمكنوا من
الطيران
لمدة 13 عامًا في مرحلة التطوير ، يعد palvey الآن
قانونيًا في الشوارع فقط في أوروبا إذا كان
معتمدًا تجاريًا للطيران ،
فقد يصل السوق في أقرب وقت ممكن في
العام المقبل ولكن لا يمكن للجميع القيام بدورة
إذا  كنت ترغب في القيادة والطيران ، نعم ،
قد تحتاج إلى رخصة طيران إضافية ،
وقد تشمل الاستخدامات المحتملة الوصول إلى
المناطق النائية حيث يمكنك القيادة و  يطير
ويقود أحلامًا كبيرة مثل كثيرين هنا في
مهرجان Goodwood للسرعة
، يتنافس الثلاثة على الاهتمام ، إنها
فرصة جيدة للعلامة التجارية للخروج إلى
هناك ،
نعم عرض ما نقوم به بالفعل
للمستثمرين المحتملين الذين
يقودون الخيال العلمي إلى حقيقة
واقعة  أقرب مما تظن